bueno antes que nada muchísimas gracias
raúl por la invitación para mí es un
gusto y un honor poder compartir con tu
público esta causa tan importante te
platico que el mexico sonríe tenemos
diferentes programas que apoyan a niños
y principalmente a mujeres también que
están pasando por un tratamiento
oncológico y ahorita que nos vamos a
enfocar en el tema de cáncer de mama te
quiero platicar de un problema que con
el que nos enfrentamos todo el tiempo
que es la consecuencia de la
quimioterapia cuando se les empieza a
caer el pelo a las mujeres ya las niñas
empiezo a tener como algunos efectos
psicológicos que les afecta
emocionalmente y en algunas ocasiones te
puedo comentar que las mujeres quieren
detener su tratamiento oncológico por
todos estos cambios físicos que van
teniendo porque la falta de aceptación
no es un tema estético es un tema de
autoestima y si aparte de estar lidiando
con un diagnóstico tan injusto y tan
complicado como es el cáncer empieza a
cambiar tu imagen física te pueden
empezar a hacer masectomía cirugías hay
muchísimos este muchísimas consecuencias
alrededor de los tratamientos
oncológicos que pueden para cambiar
nuestra imagen y es un proceso de
aceptación complicado entonces por eso
nosotros en méjico sonríe lo que
tratamos de hacer siempre es brindar
todas las herramientas necesarias para
que las niñas niños y mujeres tengan un
tratamiento médico exitoso les damos
pelucas oncológicas les apoyamos
muchísimo con el tema emocional y
psicológico tenemos una parte de
atención en crisis donde también los
pacientes nos pueden estar buscando en
caso de entrar como en un ataque de
pánico o que en caso de querer criticar
simplemente con alguien de querer
desahogarse y querer llorar en méjico
sonríe siempre tendrán una puerta para
poder tener este este canal y este
contacto y es que gaby es duro
precisamente antes de entrar a nuestro
programa estábamos hablando una en la
redacción de nuestro programa sobre este
problema emocional porque como tú le
decías no es sólo físico es una
identidad de la mujer tener pues el pelo
tener los senos o como como nacieron no
como ustedes psicológicamente las apoyan
tienen un grupo de psicólogos que es lo
que más les aqueja además
pues mira si tenemos un grupo de
psicólogos aparte tenemos una red me
atrevo a decir muy bonita que siempre
está en contacto con los pacientes
tenemos chats también de contención a
través de redes sociales de whatsapp y
este cada que un paciente lo requiere
ahí estamos para poderlo apoyar les
platicamos también cuando entregamos
pelucas oncológicas es todo un proceso
súper bonito que cada peluca tiene el
amor de 10 personas que donaron su 30
para poder crear esta peluca y poder se
las entregará a las personas entonces
les decimos que cada vez puso en esta
peluca lo vean como una herramienta que
les recuerda un poco frente al espejo
quiénes eran y quiénes van a ser después
de luchar contra esta enfermedad porque
también muchas veces cuando escuchamos
la palabra cáncer y como bien lo acabas
de comentar yo como sobreviviente de
cáncer de mama justamente escuchas la
palabra cáncer y luego luego piensas lo
peor no cuando un diagnóstico oportuno y
un tratamiento oportuno te puede hacer
un cambio radical en la historia de tu
ciudad' o sea el cáncer no es sinónimo
de muerte eso eso le quería preguntar
que es lo más importante para prevenir
esta enfermedad y que no se desarrolle
pues en el peor de los casos como ya
sabemos
es la concientización y la prevención
imagino que es lo más importante gabi
100% la detección oportuna es la clave
del tratamiento y bueno ahorita no
necesito estás enterado pero por ejemplo
también en méxico hay un tema importante
en el desabasto de medicamentos
oncológicos entonces también quiero
invitar a tu audiencia a que se acerquen
a diferentes organizaciones de la
sociedad civil que estén apoyando
justamente el tema de medicamentos
oncológicos porque una vez que se
detecta un diagnóstico tan tan
importante como es el cáncer pues sigue
la siguiente paso que es encontrar los
recursos públicos en salud en los
hospitales públicos para que se pueda
atender de manera oportuna de nada nos
va a servir la detección oportuna si no
hay tratamiento oportuno me explico si
desde su organización cuál es el
programa más especial que tienen ustedes
con respecto al cáncer grave
desde hace dos años lo más importante y
a lo que le estamos metiendo muchísimas
ganas es al tema de conseguirme terapias
para los pacientes ahorita eso es lo que
nos da como actor viendo todo el tiempo
todos los donativos toda la energía y
todo todas nuestras campanas sobre todo
imagino para llegar a las regiones de
difícil acceso porque en ciudad de
méxico pues digamos que puede haber una
cierto un cierto privilegio para las
personas por ser la capital del país
pero también cómo hacen para para
dosificar estas ayudas a las mujeres que
no viven en la capital mexicana
te platico que desgraciadamente en
ciudad de méxico tampoco hay
quimioterapias usa es un tema de
desabasto nacional y la falta de
medicamentos oncológicos es una realidad
con los pacientes que si no tienen un
seguro de gastos médicos y si no te
atienden en una institución privada no
hay quimioterapias en los hospitales
públicos hemos estado trabajando con
pacientes de los diferentes hospitales
grandes como es el hospital general de
méxico el hospital juárez de méxico el
hospital pediátrico moctesuma y
desgraciadamente no hay quimioterapias
sin importar que sea la ciudad ustedes
han conocido a personas pues a mujeres
que hayan fallecido por no recibir este
tratamiento oportuno si de hecho
justamente ahorita en agosto
desgraciadamente falleció una chiquita
de 16 años que estaba teniendo en el
instituto nacional de cancerología y
falleció por falta de medicamentos
gaby y eso yo le quería preguntar no las
mujeres jóvenes están están viendo
ustedes en su organización que de pronto
están desarrollando más cáncer
que antes sí
si fíjate que es una gran pregunta yo
creo que es muy interesante como este
tema de investigación si hay más
diagnósticos no sabría decirte si es
porque el cáncer está aumentando o
porque la concientización está
aumentando y entonces está detectando a
más mujeres no sé si me estoy dando
entendés no no sé cuál sea la variable
pero sí definitivamente o sea la curva
del cáncer ha estado aumentando y es muy
importante por eso que nos estemos
haciendo una autoexploración porque acá
te platico que eso fue lo que a mí me
pudo salvar la vida y eso que no yo
tenía todavía cuarenta años bueno
teniendo los tengo tenía 34 años cuando
me diagnosticaron cuando me sentí una
bolita y fue gracias a dios' corría al
hospital que me hicieron un ultrasonido
y una biopsia como me pude dar un
tratamiento oportuno entonces por eso me
encanta concientizar el tema de la
importancia de apoyar a las
organizaciones de la sociedad civil que
justamente acompañan a los pacientes que
no tienen a veces este vil privilegio
y atenderse oportunamente